how's your wife doing she is uh for the
time being doing okay she is she was
diagnosed in February with terminal it
metastasized to the cancer metastasized
to her liver lung bone Janice yeah yeah
that was a heavy that was a heavy couple
months trying to figure that out so for
the time being she is in a trial and I
sin so she goes a trial and for the time
being the trial is working so work okay
five months it works it's not doom and
gloom which is another you know I guess
some people go doom and gloom we never
were a doom and gloom family I never was
a doom and gloom guy she looks hot she
feels hot she doesn't you would never
know it looking at her and it's funny
she at first she didn't want to tell she
didn't want to tell her mom she didn't
want to tell a lot of people because the
first thing you get are letters
we're all praying if it's everybody
thinking they have to come visit even
though they're right in like 20 years we
brought you the best banana nut cake
this is like a really ancient recipe and
we want you to have it sorry just trying
to live my life I just yeah now we're
still good yeah she's ready religious
the prayers not mean anything or she
kind of moved away from that a little
bit no no and I don't she's she believes
she's got deep faith she definitely has
that and she's not one of those you know
there's a weird thing with religion
where people go oh how could God have
such as how could God have a child just
be killed and you've had cancer and
you're the crane that's not God [ __ ] I
don't know what people have in their
heads it's like we're human and whatever
you're into you're into she's she's all
about like hey man what
ever this journey is it's kicked ass
until now look at all that we've done
and if this is the way it's gonna go
down this is the way it goes down if I'm
not gonna gloom it and doom it if if
anything every step - has made our
visions on life a lot more clear and
crisp and you have this whole different
agenda and you realize what's really
important in life in general because
we're all on borrowed time at the end of
the day none of us again out of here so
she's pretty powerful with her faith men
when you found out in February do you go
with her to the appointment or is it oh
yeah and did you kind of know or were
you not sure do you guys sense that this
is what they were gonna say - you have
no idea no I
I knew she still had so she first the
way I found out it was I was right it
was right before I played the para
mountains like it was February like
twelfth or eleventh the last year and I
went there and soon as I came home the
next day was right before Valentine's
Day and I said what I seen the cow who's
this doctor that you've been she didn't
want to tell me and then there were I
said what are what is this doctor and
she went I have something to tell you
when Oh Shh I knew right away like what
you know we've been through it twice
what is it now
and she goes they found tumors
it could be scar tissue it could be I
just said yeah no this is hands-down I
know exactly what this I was aware they
find them it's like on my there's some
spots on my on my lung breast this to
her or did you keep it to yourself like
the feeling of dread uh no you don't you
don't put that out there you immediately
go let's see what it is let's wait for
the official word but you could tell by
her doctor at the time he wasn't very
optimistic in hours I put I call him up
say let's
and what's the deal man would it
wouldn't be looking at here what do you
release a guy you know for years I can
keep her alive there's some great pills
and let's wait for the biopsy but I'm
pretty sure I know what it is and you
know the biopsy came back and they said
it's cancer but now by the time we hit
it was a long brutal process because
when it first happens okay
well now what what what now what and
then you get tested more and the bite
and then they go and then you go to the
real specialists and they go yeah and
they they have to be very you know they
she was a young girl she look like she
was 20
she's like 27 she's like you know they
metastasized and they're in your liver
and lung and basically you're [ __ ]
maybe you'll make it to Christmas we're
not sure but them you know it's up to
you what what we can put you on a trial
and here's what so as your and I
remember I cracked a joke she said
there's drugs to give you to help you
and I went are there any drugs for me
and my wife cracked up and this woman
was as she looked at me like you and you
one try she didn't understand just about
you right and that was a heavy ride home
[Music]
your your whole life your whole you know
I've been with her for 27 28 years right
you know we're married 25 this year and
you just your whole life starts flashing
and you're it's just you going he's
thinking the kids like okay okay I'm
gonna wha all right ya know well we'll
get through this process and I'll be
alright I'll be I have to be alright
this is the next step in life this is
what it is you know this is life man
here we go and she's apologized and I'm
cracking up going don't be sorry but you
know I wish I knew your genetic pole
before we
into this I'm gonna tell others for you
married check into their Jean hole and
once their [ __ ] history and just
cracking jokes laughing and then once
she had a she we started checking out
all hospitals across the world and all
that for trials and thank God I got a
great friend that I grew up with
literally grew up on the same street
with that I've known forever and he
called he called and he always said he's
like Jimmy if you ever you let me know
though ideas you know let me know I can
I can really help and I called my like
hey here's we're at he's sent me the
papers and give me twenty minutes any
colleagues like you need to get her on a
flight tomorrow to Houston Texas so ok
food Houston and the doctors like how'd
you get in here Clark and forty year
waiting and the doctors like you need to
be in Philadelphia right now right now
you are a huge candidate you are the you
are the world's guinea pig for this
price now get on the plane head to
Philadelphia and we said oh we were in
Philadelphia and he goes why didn't you
go on the trial saying well you know I
didn't want to all the side effects
she's like he goes look at Tylenol
there's more side effect they have to
tell you that sure because or your
option is death
pick it it's up to you I mean I'm not
your life and so that's the way we've
been now the first thing they tell you
is alright once you go on the trial
normally the first month you take you
take a biopsy they gotta take a biopsy
every month it'll say the tumors are
shrinking
don't get excited it's the second third
month where you find out where this is
it working did spread of the tumors
getting big do you have less time or is
this kind of working and she didn't hear
that I recorded everything I go in a
doctor's office I recalled oh absolutely
smart
and then this way I'd I would go on a
plane and I would listen to this over
and over and I'm home back tears and
like well you're doing it for
information absolutely so she I was in I
was in Atlanta Georgia
and I got a FaceTime from her and she
was crying thinking back in the tumors
are shrunk and she's told friends if
people call me at Lisa credit but I was
you remember I was tormented because I
didn't want to crush her joy sure but I
knew in the back of my in the back of my
mind in my heart I went we're really not
gonna know [ __ ] for at least in other
months it's so but I had and then the
second month came and I was holding my
breath was right okay here we go
and they're like yeah it's it's amazing
still working so now we're up to five
months and now the doctors and all them
are super excited and pharmaceuticals
excited but you know what man there's no
I don't know how to turn this kid we
live month a month a month a month we go
hey just get another kick-ass month we
get another kick-ass so all the way back
to a shameless plug no but in
seriousness being able to do something
like this
knowing I'm home right oh yeah once a
month and if it turns into something and
I don't have to travel that much it's
you know it's uh it's definitely all a
good thing